Republicans and Democrats battle it out
over the future of the robert mueller
special council probe chuck schumer
searches for a strategy on illegal
immigration and we discussed the power
of repentance i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show so the russia probe
is all over the news we're going to
discuss that we are also going to get to
illegal immigrants trying to shut down
disneyland which is terrible it's the
happiest place on earth why would you do
that
also I'm confused why illegal immigrants
would try to shut down Disneyland it has
a wall around it and you need tickets to
enter and you are thrown out if you
Eagle e trespass so that seems like a
weird place to protest but we'll get to
all of those things first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at MVM T
so as you know MVM t make the best
watches they don't just make the best
watches they're also the best watches
for the least cost they are inexpensive
here is my MVM t watch I wear this thing
every day look how good-looking that is
I mean it's just minimalist and cool and
neatly designed it's fantastic this
company is growing incredibly fast
they've now sold over 2 million watches
or around 2 million watches in 160
countries and right now
we're running up on Valentine's Day so
ladies if you're looking to buy your
husband or boyfriend a watch and Men if
you're looking buy your girlfriend to
watch it this is the best place to do it
I've bought mbm t watches for my mom I
bought one for my wife my dad has an M
VMT watch so everyone gets MVM T watches
because they are just fantastic and
again they're cutting out the middleman
so that means that you're getting
beautiful watches like this one which
would go three to four hundred dollars
in a department store
you're getting that for you know in the
mid 100 it's just fantastic so our
friends at M VMT have put together the
perfect guide to make your life easier
whether you're shopping for him or her
and you want watches or their new
fashion for bracelets sunglasses or any
combination in their limited edition
gift box M VNT has in-house stylists who
have curated their trendiest pieces for
gift ideas your special someone will
absolutely love as I say it's really
easy to shop it's fun to shop I enjoy
looking at the M VMT website and you
will too M VMT and their stylists are
the people to trust with all of this get
15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MDM t.com slash
Shapiro that's MVM t comm slash Shapiro
that was cool at shows it's synagogue
last week and a fella walked off Burnham
II who listens to the show and he
immediately showed me his MV MT watch
because people who listen to the show
love the watches they get from em VMT
MVM t-dot-com / appear in the afib
tene percent off today with free
shipping and free returns to join the
movement MDM t-dot-com slash Shapiro
alright so I want to bring you the
latest on the Mueller investigation so
there's a lot going on in the Mueller
investigation but very little of it has
to do with Trump Russia collusion now we
were promised that Trump Russia
collusion was what this entire thing was
about it appears more and more day by
day
now this investigation has nothing to do
with Trump Russia collusion it has
everything to do with obstruction of
justice that's what it looks like it is
moving toward so on Wednesday there a
bevy of news stories about the Mueller
investigation and apparently the Special
Counsel is now trying to get Trump
himself in for an interview Trump would
be a fool to do the interview because
the minute the Trump interviews with the
guy it's a perjury trap right every time
you talk with the federal government
this is it first rule okay just as a
lawyer and this is true right left
center everybody if the police ever asks
you talk to you
the answer is wait let me call my lawyer
okay that's always the answer if you
want to be safe your answer is wait let
me call my lawyer not because you just
trust the police or you think they're
gonna do something wrong but because
you're gonna get caught in traps where
you don't know exactly how to navigate
these waters right the first word of any
defense counsel when you walk into that
room is don't talk here without a lawyer
and that would certainly be true for
Mike Flynn Mike Flynn talked to the FBI
without a lawyer and now he finds
himself i sat facing five years in
federal prison I do not talk to the FBI
without a lawyer this is certainly true
of Trump who has a tendency to babble on
at the mouth while this interview would
presumably be focused on Trump's firing
a former FBI director James Comey his
alleged request to call me to let now
indicted former national security
adviser Flynn go and his pressure on
various officials ranging from Attorney
General Jeff Sessions to Deputy FBI
director Andrew McCabe with regard to
the Trump Russia collusion investigation
so according to the Washington Post
Robert Mueller wants to investigate
Trump especially about the firings of
Flynn and Comey sessions in Comey have
both met with the special counsel
investigators already Anna sources told
the Post that Mueller quote has also
expressed interest in Trump's efforts to
remove sessions as Attorney General or
pressure him into quitting the person
said the special counsel was seeking to
determine whether there was a pattern of
behavior by the president so here's the
pattern of behavior to go back in time
according to Comey Trump asked him for a
loyalty oath back in January then in
February Trump fired Flynn because back
in December Flynn had called up the
Russian government and asked them to
vote a certain way on a resolution at
the UN and then he'd lie
about the FBI to it so Trump fires Flynn
immediately thereafter Comey says that
Trump asked Co me to let Flynn go Trump
didn't help his case when he tweeted out
that he had to let Flynn go because
Flynn lied to the FBI that makes it
sound like Trump was trying to
manipulate Comey into allowing Flynn to
get off on federal charges which could
be seen as him trying to move the
investigation in one direction or
another and then in May then then of
course Trump fires call me and then says
on national TV that he did it because of
the Russian investigation and then in
May Trump asked Andrew McCabe the deputy
FBI director how he voted in the last
election cycle when he was taking over
his interim director throughout this
period Trump was harassing Attorney
General Jeff Sessions on Twitter
presumably for accusing himself from the
Russia investigation so what exactly is
Mueller doing with all of this what here
was illegal supposedly this is all about
him obstructing justice Trump
obstructing justice getting in the way
of justice and Democrats been saying
this for months that this is the
direction they thought the investigation
was moving now note this investigation
began with the accusation that the Trump
campaign works with the Russians in
order to win the election and to stop
Hillary Clinton from becoming president
now what we're talking about has nothing
to do with any of this so you talk about
an investigation that is broadened out
and moved sideways just like every
Special Counsel investigation ever this
is what has happened here and that is
Robert Mueller's fault yeah when your
job is to find crime you find crime even
if that crime has to be manipulated on
the back of other crimes meaning that
Flynn probably didn't do anything wrong
when he called up the Russian government
but he lied to the FBI
she's caught in sort of a perjury trap
as I suggested before and then Trump is
now gonna be caught in a an obstruction
trap because he said something to call
me about it at least that is what it
looks like is happening here Dianne
Feinstein the senator from California
she's been suggesting this for months
back in December she said quote I think
what we're beginning to see is the
putting together of a case of
obstruction of justice I think we see
this in the indictments the four
indictments and the police that have
just taken place in some of the comments
that are being made I see it in the
hyper frenetic attitude of the White
House the comments every day the
continual tweets and I see it most
importantly in what happened with the
firing of former FBI director Comey it
is my belief that it is directly because
he did not agree to lift the cloud of
the Russia investigation that's
obstruction of justice now is it really
obstruction of justice as I've explained
multiple times on the show the answer is
no there are three separate federal laws
that deal with obstruction of justice
there's 18 US Code 1503 that is called
the Omnibus clause of obstruction of
justice
it covers quote corruptly or by any
threatening letter or communication
influencing or impeding or endeavoring
to influence obstruct or impede the due
administration of justice but the clause
requires a pending judicial proceeding
that was supposedly obstructed there is
no pending judicial proceeding that has
been found here as of yet okay so that
really does not apply also you'd have to
prove that Trump materially impeded the
investigation there's no real suggestion
he's done that right the special counsel
continues to investigate he hasn't fired
Robert Mueller
he fired James Comey but that didn't
stop the investigation whatever he said
to call me about investigating Flynn
didn't stop Comey from investigating
Flynn as Comey freely admitted in front
of Congress okay second clause is 18 US
Code 1512 C this provision of law covers
anyone who quote obstructs influences or
impedes an official proceeding or
attempts to do so first of all it's not
clear that an FBI investigation is
actually an official proceeding but also
you have to prove intent under this
crime you have to prove that there was
an intent to obstruct justice and a
substantial step toward the
accomplishment of that goal what was the
substantial step now maybe make the case
that the substantial step was him firing
Comey but Trump can fire call me for any
reason whatsoever that's not obstruction
of justice unless he actually stops the
investigation unless he stands in and
stops the investigation cold and says
you are no longer allowed to perform
this investigation even that may not be
able structure of justice by the way but
he would actually have to come in and
say I want you to find me innocent that
be obstruction of justice he comes in he
says I will fire you unless you find me
innocent in this probe that's probably
obstruction of justice but there is no
there's no clear evidence that that was
the case he wanted to call me to find
him innocent but I didn't shut down the
investigation after call me refused to
do so and there's 18 US Code 15-19 this
provision covers destroying evidence
there's no evidence that Trump has
destroyed evidence so what exactly is
Robert Mueller doing at this point it
looks like he's setting the groundwork
for what would be an impeachment hunt by
Democrats after the 2018 house elections
if they went back a control of the house
all over non illegal obstruction of an
investigation that found no underlying
crime other than lying to the FBI which
is a crime but is not the crime that we
were promised now Trump is gonna be
tempted to pardon everybody who lied to
the FBI
Republicans will surely defend Trump
Democrats will say this is all
impeachable because people lied to the
FBI and then Trump quote-unquote
obstructed justice even if he didn't
legally do so so he could get a nasty
knock-down drag-out fight over an issue
completely unrelated to Trump Russia
collusion right that's the direction
that
investigation is moving and it's no
wonder that people in Republican power
Republican places of power are finding
this difficult to deal with they're
finding this discomforting because this
is not what was suggested right this is
not what the investigation was
originally about Democrats said Hillary
Clinton's election was stolen Donald
Trump stole the election of Vladimir
Putin's help that obviously is not what
has happened here and no evidence has
been provided that suggests that this is
what has happened here now Democrats
aren't letting the Russia stuff go
obviously because they can they've told
their base that Russia Russia Russia
Russia is behind everything like just
today Dianne Feinstein and Adam Schiff
both Democrats from California pushed
Facebook and Twitter to investigate the
release the memo social media campaign
like that campaign as you recall we've
talked about it for the last week that
is a campaign to release Devin nuñez's
House Intelligence memo that apparently
compiles a bunch of failures of FISA
including presumably that FISA based its
original investigation its original
warrant on Carter page from foreign
policy advisor on bad Intel right on bad
Intel provided by a democratic capo firm
so now Feinstein and Schiff are pushing
Facebook and Twitter suggesting that
perhaps Russian bots are manipulating
the hashtag released the memo the whole
goal here by the way is to push Facebook
and Twitter so they shut down
conservative news and information that's
what the Democrats want to do here so
they are corrupted they are pushing the
rush of stuff in a way that is dishonest
I think but you know I think that
there's there's another side to this
story too and in a second I'm gonna
discuss the other sides of this story
because the way that Republicans are
responding to this investigation could
be right and it could be very wrong now
I'll explain what I mean by that in just
a second first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over equip so you have a
face on that face is a mouth in that
mouth our teeth and if you do not
properly brush your teeth then you could
die and that's not really an
exaggeration the fact is that heart
health has actually been pretty
significantly linked to oral health and
when it comes to your health it's
probable that you're not brushing your
teeth correctly well that's why you need
quick quip is the new electric
toothbrush that packs just the right
amount of vibration into a slim design
in a fraction of the cost of bulkier
traditional electric brushes right it
comes complete with pulsing alert to
tell you when to switch sides making
brushing the right amount effortless it
also comes to the mount that sections
right to your mirror on sticks to use as
a cover for hygienic travel anywhere
whether it's going in your gym bag or in
your carry-on it's easy to travel this
electric tooth
I travel all the time and Hartford
Connecticut today speaking at UConn I've
got my equipped toothbrush with me
because I don't have to bring this huge
recharger the battery fits right inside
the toothbrush which means that you just
stick it in your travel bag and you are
basically ready to go
clip subscription plan also ensures that
your brush is refreshed on a dentist
recommended schedule delivering new
brush heads every three months for just
five dollars including free shipping
worldwide clip is backed by a networked
order 10,000 dental professionals most
toothbrushes don't get named one of the
best inventions of the Year by Time
magazine but quit did
there's a reason quip starts at just 25
bucks and if you go to get quip comm
slash Shapiro that's GE t qu IP comm
slash Shapiro right now you get your
first refill pack free with a quip
electric toothbrush that's your first
refill pack free at get quip comm slash
Shapiro again that is get quip comm
slash up here o GE tqu IP comm slash
Shapiro and right now you get your first
refill pack free plus when you use the
slash tip here that lets them know that
we sent you as well so that always helps
with our advertisers so check that out
as well okay so with all of this said
about the Mueller investigation
there is another controversy that has
arisen and that of course is whether the
Mueller investigation should be done
away with completely now the Republican
case that the Mueller investigation
should be done away with completely is
not the Mueller investigation has found
nothing on Trump Russia so far because
we don't know that right we don't know
what Mueller has found he hasn't
revealed that and it's a little bit of a
jump from saying that the investigation
was initially compromised to suggesting
that the entire investigation will find
nothing we just don't know right by all
implication I would think that they
really have nothing that's my opinion
though I don't have the underlying facts
and so I'm trying to separate my own
opinion from the facts so we'll have to
wait to find out whether the Mueller
investigation actually finds something
if all they find is Flynn and
obstruction of justice I think everyone
is going to be disappointed and should
be at least in terms of what they were
promised so meanwhile the Republicans
are attacking the investigation itself
by is hacking the FBI here is the
problem either the FBI was corrupted by
Democrats or it is not corrupt and
Republicans are corrupting the FBI and
and targeting the FBI to defend Trump
neither of these answers is good neither
of these is good for the country if it
turns out the Democrats compromised the
FBI an attempt to stop President Trump
from becoming president and then
continued to use the FBI in an attempt
to curb Trump's presidency then that is
corruption at the highest levels that is
the destruction of one of the great
American institutions
destruction of a law-enforcement agency
that requires the trust of the American
people
it's just along the lines of the Obama
administration compromising the IRS and
using it as a political baton so that's
option number one Republicans are right
and the FBI has been significantly
compromised by Democrats and there is a
quote-unquote deep state problem going
on
then there's Theory number two then
there's Theory number two right theory
number two is that the Democrats did not
actually compromise the FBI the FBI may
have some problematic figures like Peter
struck and Lisa Paige in it but that
does not mean the FBI's actually
compromised the investigation is moving
as most investigations do there's not
serious democratic infiltration of the
FBI it's just working as a law
enforcement agency does in which case
Republicans are targeting a law
enforcement agency for Destruction in
order to defend President Trump which is
a really really bad look okay here's the
basis for all of this so in the last few
weeks heard the revelations regarding
alleged collusion between the Trump
campaign and the Russian government and
most of all regarding the FBI's
investigation of it okay text messages
between FBI agents Peter struck and his
mistress Lisa Paige talked openly about
a quarter unquote path you threw out for
consideration in deputy director Andrew
McCabe's office as a quote insurance
policy in the unlikely event you die
before you're 40 with reference to a
trump election meaning we I mean here's
how it reads anyway just to a layman
what it reads like is we have an
insurance policy against Trump being
elected and that is this investigation
into into Trump right struck worked
heavily on the Hillary investigation he
helped exonerate her he was also deeply
involved in the Trump Russia collusion
investigation
hey that's breaking story number one
breaking Story number two
representatives trey Gowdy and John
Ratcliffe they said that there are text
messages between struck and and page
that referenced a quote-unquote secret
society working against Trump we haven't
seen any of that so far and now Senator
Ron Johnson who had echoed those
comments he said that his secret society
comments were based on an informant and
the words used in the struck page text
exchange he says he does not know
exactly what they meant so everybody is
taking that super seriously and
suggesting that the secret society is
some sort of you know Bilderberg
conspiracy to take down Trump inside the
FBI Ron Johnson is saying that he
doesn't really know what that means so
we got to take all that with a grain of
salt
Lorna theory is that the FBI somehow
lost a batch of text messages between
struck and page they turned over about
50,000
struck page text messages but the period
in which they do not have messages from
struck to page and vice versa is
December 2016 to May 2017 which is
during this entire compromising period
writes during the bulk of the
investigation into Flynn the firing of
Comey
the the supposed via quasi threats he
Andrew McCabe okay and apparently the
text messages stopped going missing
conveniently enough the day that Robert
Mueller took over the part of the probe
which suggests that maybe they were
texting about James Comey and then they
got rid of all of those texts all those
texts were deleted or the FBI got rid of
all of them as soon as Mueller took over
because it made the investigation look
bad
okay the FBI did change its language
regarding Hillary Clinton before Hillary
was even interviewed and of course the
the news that the Democrats hate is this
House Intelligence Committee chairman
Nunez four-page memo that purportedly
blew the lid off the FISA malfeasance in
the Trump Russia collusion case
presumably suggesting that the original
FISA warrants against Carter page was
garnered based on a bad dossier compiled
by fusion GPS at the behalf of Democrats
and in collusion with the Obama
administration the DOJ and the FBI okay
so that's all of the that's all of the
information now here's the question is
the FBI actually a corrupt deeply
corrupt place so they're a bunch of
Republicans who are suggesting that the
answer is yes that there's a deeply
corrupt thing going on here right
President Trump is suggesting this
himself president Trump tweeted this out
yesterday he tweeted out well where are
the fifty thousand important text
messages between FBI lovers Lisa Paige
and Peter struck blaming Samsung right
so that of course is a joke
the Democrats in the media don't
understand a joke so they thought that
Trump was actually blaming Samsung which
is idiotic he is joking that the FBI did
away with these there were not by the
way fifty thousand text messages that
were lost between struck and page
they're fifty thousand text messages
total between struck and page and some
of those were lost we don't know exactly
how many now sarah huckabee sanders says
that she that the Trump is deeply
concerned that the FBI agents are biased
against him and that the FBI has been
deeply corrupted and compromised why
does he think this is
I think he thinks that there's a great
cause for concern that five months worth
of text messages have gone missing
particularly given the individual that
has part of that process has already
been shown to be extremely biased
against the president and was involved
in what seems to be some very
inappropriate behavior and that
certainly is a great concern you guys
are absolutely obsessed with everything
to do with collusion if it has anything
to do with the president we hope that
you'll take some of that same obsession
energy and fervor and direct it to some
of the places where it looks like there
could have been some really
inappropriate and possibly illegal
behavior okay so obviously the Trump
administration thinks that the FBI is
going after them Ron Johnson as I
mentioned the senator from Wisconsin he
is suggesting the same thing he says we
see serious corruption inside the FBI so
when the DOJ censured this letter saying
that there was this glitch that
prevented those five months of text from
being released to you did you buy it or
do you buy it
well I'm suspicious I want to get to the
bottom of it and there's so many experts
in IT that say that those messages are
somewhere and they need to be retrieved
we need to see because the timing is
very suspicious from mid December of
2016 after the election until the day
that Robert Muller was actually
appointed what this is all about is
further evidence of corruption more than
bias but corruption at the highest
levels of the FBI and that secret
society okay so this is the Republican
theory right there the Republic the
Republican theory is that is that the
Trump administration is being targeted
from inside the FBI by a secret society
you know this all sounds conspiratorial
maybe it is maybe it isn't but one of
two things is true either the FBI is
deeply corrupt or the Republicans are
targeting the FBI in order to defend
Trump which would be deeply corrupt in
and of itself you know I was really
disappointed yesterday Rush Limbaugh who
of course I'm a big fan of he's the
granddaddy of us all in in talk radio
and in in sort of the conservative
commentary at least those of us who
speak for a living yesterday rush I
thought went over the line when he was
discussing the Intel community he
suggested in almost true therus fashion
that maybe the Iraq war Intel was
compromised in order to get Bush
maybe the Intel community has always
been out to get Republican presidents
here's what Rush had to say yesterday
you remember what the agencies were
telling this is the war in Iraq
do you remember what they were telling
us there was detail there were photos
there was conclusive evidence Saddam
Hussein had weapons of mass destruction
and it wasn't just us until it was mi5
mi6 it was intelligence agencies all
over the world what if just what if
remember they all thought Gore had won
that election until the Supreme Court
came along and stole it for Bush this is
what they thought the Democrat Party is
the Washington establishment and the
Washington establishment believes that
Gore won the presidency in the Florida
recount aftermath was bogus
okay rush goes on here it says basically
suggests then maybe the Iraq war Intel
was compromised in order to get bush
which doesn't make any sense along the
time line the Iraq war wasn't launched
until 2003 Bush was elected in 2000
beyond that the Iraq war never would've
gone forward if it had not been for 9/11
Ann Coulter has been targeting the FBI
as well suggesting the FBI was always
corrupted what's weird is the chief
she's conflating corrupt and incompetent
the FBI has certainly made mistakes no
question about it right she suggests
that the FBI is responsible for for 9/11
to a certain extent which i think is
dubious in the extreme but this is the
danger that Republicans run into okay
you can question corruption at the FBI
without even questioning the corruption
of the entire institution you can say
there are bad apples at the FBI who
corrupted this investigation fruit of
the poisonous tree doctrine the entire
investigations corrupt but instead
Republicans are falling into this trap
of now targeting the entire FBI which of
course is not good for the country and
it's especially not good for the country
if the Republican Party is corruptly
targeting the FBI because there is
something there and they're just
defending Trump no matter what I don't
know enough to answer this question you
don't know enough to answer this
question the only way this question gets
answered is once we know exactly what
Mueller knows know what was in that file
which by the way Trump can declassify at
any time that FISA warrants on Carter
page I want to know what's in that
warrant don't you Trump can Declassified
it any time I want more information
whether before I decide that either the
FBI is corrupt or that the Republicans
are corrupt for calling the FBI corrupt
right one of these two things is
apparently true and there is no third
answer right there really is no third
answer maybe there's a third answer I
think that
answer actually would be that there are
members of the FBI who are corrupt like
Peter struck and Lisa Paige but not the
entire FBI and that doesn't necessarily
compromise the entire investigation or
if it does compromise the entire
investigation that's not an indictment
of the entire FBI that would be I think
the reasonable third position but those
are not the positions people are taking
Democrats are saying the FBI is spotless
and therefore Trump was engaged in
obstruction of justice in attempting to
get the FBI Republicans are saying the
FBI is deeply corrupt and was corrupted
by the Obama administration and
therefore ending the Mueller
investigation is necessary
I don't think actually either of those
two positions are correct and I think
both of them lack significant evidence
well on just one second and move on to
the B fallout from daca and and what's
coming next on the DAC negotiations
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsor is over at Dollar Shave Club so
you've heard me talk about the great
razors you get from Dollar Shave Club
especially when you use their dr.
Carver's at shave butter but they have
all of these great products for the
bathroom you no longer have to go to
your local pharmacy and try to pick up
your local Rite Aid or CVS and try to
pick up the best available products and
decide between a thousand of them
instead they come directly to your house
Dollar Shave Club makes products for
your hair face skin shower everything
you need listen you you all know I look
amazing but I also smell amazing and I'm
not gonna ask people at the office to
attest to this but my wife can attest to
this it's all of their own original
stuff there's only the finest premium
ingredients they deliver it to you just
like they do their razors and that means
no more annoying trips to the store I
use Dollar Shave Club for pretty much
everything they have razors they body
cleanser they had hair gel and yes their
world-famous butt wipes indeed the butt
wipes so now's a great time to give
Dollar Shave Club a try and get your
first month of their best razor along
with travel sized versions of the shave
butter body cleanser and those infamous
butt wipes for just $5 after that the
replacement cartridges ship for just a
few bucks a month
it's the DFC starters that get yours for
just five bucks exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com slash been uses
flash pens he gets a special deal dollar
shave club calm slash Ben and for and
freezing the slash pen you get your
first month of their best razor along
with the travel sized versions of again
the shea butter the body cleanser and
those magical butt wipes you get all of
those for just $5 at dollarshaveclub.com
slash money to try it out plus when you
use slash pen that lets them know that
we sent you okay so while all of this
unfolds on the Mueller investigation and
basically the temptation for Trump here
is going to be fire Mueller pardon
everyone and this thing as soon as it's
I think that would be a big mistake at
this point believe me if it turns out
that there's nothing to the Mueller
investigation if it turns out that this
is really I think flimsy stuff then
people will out there be out there on
mass defending Trump right I'll be out
there I'll be out there defending Trump
I mean I've been trying to take as much
as I can't a factually based look at
what's happening here and try and base
my opinion on those facts so I'm gonna
wait for more facts to decide whether or
not this investigation is just deeply
corrupt I will say that it looks like
there are problems inside the FBI
I don't know those problems go to the
entire FBI I don't know they discredit
the entire investigation I'll also say
that you know the pattern of obstruction
that Muller is trying to find in Trump
can be explained one of two ways either
Trump is trying to obstruct justice in
order to defend his friends and hide
from something nefarious or Trump is
dolt is a dolt and and he just says
stuff because he feels it like I like
Flynn they call me could you leave Milan
or Flynn's or commis annoying me because
he won't just say I'm innocent
I know I'm innocent he's fired all right
I think honestly what makes all of these
scandals seem to seem to go away a
little bit anyway is if you suggest that
they are mostly based on stupidity
rather than malice when it comes to
government that is oh that's almost
always a good bet it's not just for
Trump it's true pretty much everyone's
stupidity rather than malice usually
rules the day when it is mouse it's
pretty clear like Adam Schiff and Diane
Feinstein suggesting the Russian bots
are behind release the memo that's
malice to me because Feinstein and
Schiff are both smart people and they
know better than this but this most all
of this mostly looks like an insane
amount of stupidity piled on top of
stupidity rather than malice in a get
Trump effort but my mind is willing to
be persuaded on any of these scores I
just need more evidence
okay so meanwhile more fallout from daca
so obviously the government shutdown
ended earlier this week Democrats got
nothing in return but they are receiving
some protests which is which is quite
entertaining apparently they're a bunch
of daca recipients dreamers actually
went outside Chuck Schumer's house and
were protesting outside chuck schumer's
house yesterday that wasn't the only
place that they were protesting by the
way they apparently blocked an entrance
to Disneyland on Monday now we were at
Disneyland on Sunday we had a great time
met some fans which was always a party
when it's kind of fun going to places
like Disneyland you meet a lot of
listeners and and hello to all of the
people I met at Disneyland that was
always party but according to the LA
Times the next day monday daca
recipients stood in a crosswalk at South
Harbor
around 10:00 a.m. and blocked buses from
entering the Anaheim theme park 15
protesters were quickly removed by law
enforcement officers and were relocated
to a sidewalk where they held signs and
chanted no dream no deal so it's about
20 people and Disneyland operated
completely normally I do have a question
as I say as a regular Disneyland patron
and yes season ticket holder I have two
young children this is insanely idiotic
what in the hell does the happiest place
on earth have to do with people
illegally in the country retaining their
ability to stay in the country it ought
to be noted that Disneyland has a pretty
strict immigration policy no ticket no
entry and they have a wall a giant fence
around the entire park and if you try to
climb the wall they will call the police
on you so Disneyland unless they are
protesting for free entry to Disneyland
which is something I might be able to
get behind on occasion I don't know why
they would do this but it just
demonstrates the demonstrators
themselves just do things without really
any thought simply to get the press
meanwhile Chuck Schumer is idiotic Lee
trying to blackmail Republicans I don't
think any of this is going anywhere as I
suggested yesterday I don't think a daca
deal was imminent I don't think that
Mitch McConnell is going to push one I
don't think Trump is going to sign one I
think in all likelihood we hit the March
5th deadline for for reinstating for for
reinstating deportations and Trump just
says listen we're not gonna give you
papers but we're also not going to
deport most of the dreamers and they go
back to sort of this in the shadows in
between status I got some emails
yesterday and they're quite correct
suggesting this is bad for the dreamers
because with their current sort of green
card status they can get jobs Trump
would prevent them from getting jobs the
truth is that illegal immigrants in this
country have been working for a very
long time which is how they've been able
to stay in the country and and yes it
will revoke certain legal status in
terms of work but it won't it won't
actually deport them anyway Chuck
Schumer is trying to blackmail McConnell
saying you have 16 days or or or I'm
gonna get really mad like he's saying
that he's not gonna shut down the
government again so I'm or at least he's
implied that so I'm not sure what the
other what the stick is I understand
that the carrot is the dock ideology
don't know what the stick is here's
Chuck Schumer Center Minority Leader
warning McConnell so the Republican
majority now has 16 days to work with us
to write a bill that can get 60 votes
and prevent the dreamers from being
deported the clock is ticking 16 days
that's not much time
gotta get moving okay so I don't know
what what clock is ticking like on
February 8th they gonna shut down the
government again I mean Schumer just
gave well as leverage
he also said yesterday that he was
pretty obvious the Democrats weren't
gonna be willing to shut down the
government for the dreamers I mean he
said this literally yesterday now for
two days the government was shut down
but all of us in the Democratic caucus
not just the moderates but the Liberals
as well came to the view that if we
carried it on much longer two things
would happen a no one would budge the
public would lose support of the shut
down the public does not like shutdowns
and we'd actually lose support for
dreamers too because people love the
dreamers but don't want the government
shutdown for it so we cut the best deal
that we could so I'm really confused as
to what the threat is he's saying you
know 16 days or I won't shut down the
government again because our people
don't want us to do this and good luck
with that strategy yeah it's going
nowhere the realities Schumer doesn't
want to deal because he wants to be able
to claim Republicans stopped the deal
Republicans do want to deal but not on
the terms Democrats are offering and the
Democrats are basically offering nothing
now I mean Schumer yesterday decided
that he was gonna withdraw his pittance
of an offer one point six billion
dollars in border security in return for
legal status for the dreamers and their
parents and Trump said no and then
Schumer withdrew the offer after Trump
said no so this is going and this is
going nowhere
what is hilarious I mentioned is the
dreamers showing up a truck shimmers
house here here are some of the dreamers
protesting outside Schumer's house
[Music]
okay he says if Chuck won't let us dream
then we won't let him sleep the note to
these people Chuck Schumer was not
sleeping in his house last night he was
in Washington DC so there are very
bright stuff again the Democrats are
offering nothing Blumenthal a senator
senator Blumenthal from Connecticut he
Richard Blumenthal he he said that
Democrats would support increased border
security but no wall so obviously this
negotiation is going nowhere a border
wall is a waste of money squandering
billions of dollars on an ineffective
solution of border security is really
reprehensible so we are going to be
supporting border security surveillance
drones more training for the agents who
are there and additional agents the guys
nonsense they don't want more border
security they don't want to deal right
then they don't want to deal of any sort
here okay so here's so here's the
reality the Democrats are not interested
in a deal because Democrats aren't in
favor of illegal immigration okay they
really are okay the reason that I say
this is because the the state of
California my home state one of the
perhaps I don't think perhaps that is
the dumbest state the dumbest state in
the Union apparently there's a new
California policy and it begins on April
2nd that automatically registers people
who obtain or renew driver's licenses to
vote okay this is this is the new policy
the new the new state policy is that you
are registered to vote automatically
when you obtain or renew your driver's
license well here's the problem in the
state of California illegal immigrants
have driver's licenses so you can renew
you can actually register to vote in the
state of California as an illegal
immigrant right now so the the idea that
they're trying to crack down on the
dilemma grants is silly by the way there
are certain principalities I believe in
California where they're openly saying
maybe we should allow illegal immigrants
to vote we'll just give them to facto
citizenship and allow them to vote so
pretty amazing stuff but Democrats
obviously have an interest in the
continuation of illegal immigration
that's why they are fighting so hard
against a border security and that is
constantly worth pointing out okay in
just a second I'm gonna discuss with you
the latest that's happening at Yukon I'm
supposed to speak at University of
Connecticut tonight Plus is it
worthwhile to forgive President Trump
for his sins for his trespasses
because it seems like some evangelicals
are willing to do just that and I'll
discuss whether that's appropriate or
not but first you're gonna have to go
over and subscribe so first of all
before we get to that I just want to say
that on January 30th you need to be
watching because our president is gonna
be speaking to the nation in the first
State of the Union address right it's
gonna be a really exciting event and you
should watch it with us here at the
daily what we're doing a special
broadcast can be awesome starting at
8:00 p.m. Eastern 5:00 p.m. Pacific
we're gonna be hanging out with you the
entire time leading up to during after
the address will be there for every wild
hand gesture for every crazy statement
for every Democrat refusing to stand for
particular heroes we will be there for
all of it right and you can catch the
live streams a daily wire daily wire
Facebook or daily Y our YouTube to spend
the evening with me with Andrew Klavan
with Michael moles and with daily Wired
god-king Jeremy boring and a bunch of
special guests who are going to be
dropping by people that you know and
love and who may not have mugs we're
gonna be having all of them in to
relentlessly mock our government and our
political leaders it'll basically be
like MS 3tk Mystery Science Theater
it'll be like that except with politics
so it should be a lot of fun if you
watched our election night broadcast it
was a lot of fun this should be even
more fun because there isn't the the
pressure of worrying about Hillary
Clinton becoming president and or Donald
Trump becoming president so that's next
Tuesday January 30th 8 p.m. Eastern 5:00
p.m. Pacific follow us on Facebook and
YouTube get notified when we go live so
we can spend every single terrible
moment of the state I hate the State of
the Union I freaking hate it I think the
state of unions garbage I'll talk about
that more next week but I really really
hate the State of the Union I think it's
an imperial spectacle that is absolute
nonsense and Horse and hogwash it is not
mandated by the Constitution okay the
Constitution suggests that the president
can be requested to give an update to
Congress from time to time he could send
it in a letter that I think would be
better but instead we're all gonna have
to pretend to think there's a great
American spectacle left anyway we're
gonna be there and be negative and
terrible about it
or at least I will and then Michael
Mills and Andrew Clavin will be all
happy to happy do about it and then turn
me boring will sit there and drinks
that'll basically be how the evening
goes and you can join us again it's a
Lee Weyer Facebook daily wire YouTube my
Facebook page as well daily wire calm
all the usual places for that ok now if
you want to subscribe to the show $9.99
a month get to a subscription to daily
wire.com and when you get that
subscription daily where to come to get
the rest of my show live you get to be
part of my mailbag you get Clavin the
show live Knowles's show live you also
get with the annual subscription $99 a
year our world-famous
daily wire
leftist to tears hot or cold tumblr I
got a great enough from somebody today
actually about the tumblr apparently
this fellow works at a leftist company
and it keeps the tumblr in his car he
drinks coffee on the way to and from
work and apparently he walked into the
office and there was a guy he was
supposed to interview with and the guy
hurriedly took his daily wire Facebook
his daily wire tumblr off his desk and
hid it in his drawer and so our stalwart
friends then had a half hour meeting
about how awesome we are you can be part
of that secret society our own daily
wire secret society by becoming an
annual member and getting the leftist
tears hot or cold tumblr which is your
past passcode it is your ticket to the
secret society also just wanna listen
later iTunes SoundCloud stitcher Google
Play all of these places have our
podcast on audio you can subscribe at
YouTube as well we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
all righty so I want to give you the
update from the University of
Connecticut so I am supposed to speak at
University of Connecticut tonight
originally this event was open to the
public as always as usual the left made
enough trouble that now they're they're
staffing up with police officers and
they have barred the general public from
attending the speech which is just in
nain apparently we're only in a room
that fits about 250 people there have
been over 500 student reservations and a
minimum if they'd open it up to the
public that probably would've been
another thousand but as it is it is
restricted to students alone they say
for security reasons oddly enough when
Anita Hill spoke here just about a month
and a half ago there was no security
presence necessary essentially and
everyone from the general public was
allowed to attend this is the new way of
preventing the message from getting out
is by preventing the public from coming
and listening now I'm not gonna put that
all on UConn I don't think it's the
administration that is that is making
this making this issue happen except to
the extent that they are allowing the
HEC waters veto to prevent the public
from hearing what we do so that is
happening tonight at 7 p.m. at Yukons
we'll be speaking there the aunt the
anti-fog Rupe there is upset with me
apparently they had encouraged people to
show up and directly confront Lucia
Nguyen French but instead of protesting
me directly they say that they are going
to set up a parallel event with some guy
that I've really never heard of who's
kind of an obscure gadfly who his only
as far as I can tell his only prominence
in life has come from writing a piece
about me for an for a magazine that he
self funds or funds on charitable
contributions and that nobody has ever
read except for this one article about
me he's speaking at the same time so I
will say I am very excited that I have
generated an entire Bendis tree I'm very
excited that I have generated an entire
cottage industry of people who can just
follow me around critiquing me so that's
exciting but they're having a separate
event because they're trying to draw
people away from hearing my message
because this is what the left does
instead of holding their events at a
different time or coming to the event
and then asking questions instead
they're going to hold a separate event
where they have some guys who liberally
misconstrue everything I've ever written
and then talk about how I'm not as smart
as I think I am that's actually the
title of it that I'm not as insightful
as I think I am which is weird so I
actually don't think I'm that insightful
I actually think that I say things that
are pretty obvious most of the time in
any case and Tifa says that I am an
extreme conservative who thrives on
media attention of the campus opposition
so rather than getting people to fill
out to fill the auditorium
we decided our general meeting to
support students pushing for alternative
programming to counter his toxic and
politics so no good
yeah don't show up and we might ruin my
event that's great I'd prefer I'd much
prefer to to push instead for for
civilized conversation my favorite part
of their little letter to the editor is
that my beliefs caused me to overlook
the need for ethnic studies and
diversity related education in the
United States who know oh no I oppose
ethnic studies ooh
useless branches of study that provides
zero jobs to anyone outside of the
ethnic studies divisions at universities
like you come on so they've decided that
they're going to fight for Scioscia
fight for social injustice that makes
sense they're fighting for social
injustice that's true in our own forums
in which we frame the message they're
not gonna come to my event tonight
that's fine with me I don't need you in
my event it turns out to get the crowd
out turns out a lot of people want to
hear what I have to say anyway so so
that is so that works for me so we'll
give you all of the updates tomorrow
after this speech beyond that in other
news there is a lot of hubbub and now
over over comments from Tony Perkins of
the Family Research Council so I know
Tony Perkins I like Tony Perkins but he
he made some comments that I thought
were were sort of weird regarding bad
behavior in public fora so here is what
Tony Perkins had to say about president
Trump and his bad behavior in 2016 he
allegedly paid off a pornstar 130,000
dollars to avoid talking about an affair
that they had while he was married
Melania and shortly after she'd given
birth to their son Barron I here's tony
perkins defending trump let me try
understand you used the exact word
mulligan to talk about this and
obviously the most recent allegations
involve an affair with a porn star that
began a few months after his wife gave
birth the president's wife and they also
involved the president's personal
attorney reportedly paying off the porn
star for her silence and you're saying
you got a mulligan you get a do-over
here I'm quoting you why well if this
behavior were occurring today right now
as he is president United States I can
assure you that's my support and support
of Evangelicals would be dissipating
very rapidly but we're talking about
something that occurred ten years ago
among a number of things that occurred
with this president prior to being
president and myself along with
a lot of Evangelicals were not
supportive of him in the primary in fact
I've campaigned hard for one of his
competitors
it was windows down to him and Hillary
Clinton he wanted to have the support of
evangelicals and he came to them saying
I'm gonna pro pro pro life justices I'm
picking a pro-life conservative running
mate so here's my big problem with all
of this okay so he's basically saying
the Trump gets a mulligan because it
happened ten years ago okay you don't
get a mulligan what you do get is us
saying you like your policies but please
you having sex with porn stars and then
paying them off allegedly is disgusting
behavior and inexcusable and gross and I
don't understand for the life of me why
religious people Christians Jews anyone
can't understand the simple distinction
you don't have to defend every bad thing
that Trump does or give him a mulligan
on it just because he's doing a bunch of
stuff that you like lots of people do
stuff that I like Bill Clinton pursued
policies that today I would like in
terms of deficit reduction okay that
doesn't mean that I gave him a pass on
all of his evils and the idea by the way
that evangelicals or religious people
would would break with Trump on mass if
it turned out he was having sex with a
porn star right now in the White House
is just not true it's just not true I
don't see any basis for that in any of
the polling data that I've seen so far
and this is anti biblical okay I'm just
gonna put it out there it is the
anti-biblical to suggest that Trump gets
a mulligan you got to do over for it for
the evils that he has committed when
he's never repented when he's never
repented so normally we saved the Bible
segment for the end of the show but let
me talk a little bit about what the
Bible has to say about repentance
because President Trump is somebody who
has said that he doesn't seek
forgiveness right these back in 2015
Trump was asked about seeking
forgiveness and here's what he had to
say Donald Trump was having difficulty
to even talking about his own
relationship with God he was asked
several times about that he wasn't even
able to say so in an ask point-blank has
he ever asked God for forgiveness Donald
Trump said no okay so if you never were
able to ask God for forgiveness let me
just point this out okay the reason that
he is not like David is because David
did repent okay Psalm thirty two David
famously repents right it says of David
blessed is the one whose transgressions
are forgiven whose sins are covered
blessed is the one whose sin the lord
does not count against them and who in
whose spirit is no deceit when I kept
silent my bones wasted away through my
groaning all day long for day and night
your hand was heavy on me my strength
was sapped as in the heat of
then I acknowledged my sin to you and
did not cover up my iniquity I said I
will confess my transgressions to the
Lord and you forgave the guilt of my sin
right that's the point if you want to
rejoice in the Lord you actually have to
confess you actually have to repent this
is something Trump has not done so does
not tony Perkins his job or my job or
your job right absolution to the
president on these charges the president
is gonna have to go to God for that
absolution right we can say that we back
all of his policy when it comes to
abortion we back his policy when it
comes to religious freedom we back a lot
of his policies America when it comes to
judges but it is not our job to give him
Mulligan's on personal transgressions
okay if you can't hold these two
thoughts in your in your head at the
same time I would suggest that you are
doing something wrong I think part of
the problem here is that there has been
a widespread worship of government that
is spread throughout the land there's a
poll from yesterday from the Wall Street
journal/nbc that suggests Americans when
they were asked whether government
should do more or whether government is
already doing too much
they split 58 38 right saying that that
the government should do more 58%
whether the government is already doing
too much a 38 percent worth noting in
1995 after the after Congress took over
after Republicans took over Congress and
the Republican revolution of Gingrich
the split was 32 percent said more
government 62% said less government in
October 27 2010 just before the GOP
swamped Democrats and took back the
house that divided was 54 45 to 50 so in
other words more Americans thought we
should do have a government that does
less then have a government that does
more but ever since we've thought that
government ought to do more and that now
includes a large number of Republicans
right a huge number of Republicans now
say that the government should do more
right so if you look at January 2010 the
role of government 17% of Republicans in
2010 said that the government should do
more today that number has almost
doubled 33 percent of Republicans say
the government should do more if you
think that the government is going to
save you if you think the government's
job is to is to help you and save you
and enrich your life and it's not just
there to protect you then you're more
likely to give a lot of leeway to
politicians you're gonna say I want the
guy in charge who agrees with me because
the government needs to save me the
government needs to help me this is a
mistake it's a big mistake hey you
shouldn't be worshiping that
ahead of the government just cuz he's
the head of the government and you
shouldn't be making excuses or giving
him Mulligan's over behavior that he has
not repented for I find this this whole
thing rather distasteful
now speaking of distasteful in John
Kerry apparently John Kerry did
something so insane yesterday or the day
before that it's just it's it's
ridiculous according to The Jerusalem
Post the White House confirms that since
the Jerusalem declaration there's been a
complete disconnect between the
Palestinian Authority and the Trump
administration but it now turns out the
previous administration maintains
contact with PA officials Maariv
reported that former unity Israeli
newspaper reported that Secretary of
State John Kerry met in London with a
close associate of terrorists
Palestinian Authority President Mahmoud
Abbas terrorist is my word for a long an
open conversation apparently the this
this guy who's representing Abbas a guy
named Hussein Agha reported details of
the conversation to senior PA officials
in Ramallah a senior pay official closer
confirmed Temari of the meeting took
place so what exactly did Kerry say
listen to this this is insane
during the conversation according to the
report John Kerry asked akka to convey a
message to Abbas and to ask him to hold
on and be strong tell Abbas a terrorist
leader who openly came out two weeks ago
and said the trumps house she basically
burned down and suggest that nikki
hailey should feel the wrath of god and
suggested that israel is not Jewish
territory and suggested that terrorism
ought to be pursued hold on and be
strong this is the minute the former
administration that goes around saying
that Trump is danger to the Middle East
in the world this administration the
Obama administration I mean you wonder
why evangelicals rally to trump they
shouldn't rally do his sins but you want
to ride a rally to trump it's because of
garbage like this John Kerry apparently
told a guy who was again the stand-in
for Malcolm to boss who's now serving
the 14th year of his four-year election
term he's originally elected back in
2004 for a four-year term he's never
given up power since he's the quasi
dictator apparently Kerry said that that
Abbas should quote stay strong in his
spirit and play for time he will not
break
he will not yield to president Trump's
to mounds so you have Kerry over there
performing his own foreign policy
hilarious that Mike Flynn is basically
gonna go to jail because he lied to the
FBI about a supposed violation of the
Logan Act you got John Kerry going out
openly saying two foreign terrorists by
the way just hold on don't do anything
we're coming and we're gonna help you
funny how the media don't seem to care
about this story very much funny how
it's just the right-wing media picking
up on this and the Jerusalem Post and
when Mike Flynn was talking to the
Russians during the transition this is a
big story but John Kerry who's not in
power and hasn't been in power for a
year and a half
John Kerry is is is sitting around
talking with with with the Palestinian
terrorists about why they should hold
the hold up hope against Trump and then
he said maybe it is time for the
Palestinians to find their peace
principles and present a positive plan
and then he suggested that he was gonna
run for president and he suggested that
if he just waits till 2020 then Trump
will be ousted and perhaps Kerry will
run for president this is why
Republicans do not trust Democrats it's
why people don't trust the media if the
media refused to cover stories like this
but they are gonna go hog-wild over
Trump Russia collusion no wonder the
media has has lost the trust of the
American people okay so now let's do
some things I like and some things that
I hate so a couple of one quick thing
that I like today so we've been doing
fantasy stories this of course is the
classic fantasy story of all time
it's Alice's Adventures in Wonderland by
Lewis Carroll it's just a delightful
book you know forget about all of the
allegations about Lewis Carroll for just
a second because I don't think we need
to get into you know whether he was into
small children in order to judge the
quality of his work this is actually an
interesting issue there are a lot of
people who think that if somebody's a
really bad person that we can't enjoy
their art I've always found this a
bizarre stipulation if the art itself is
replete with the disgustingness that's
one thing but if you're just saying that
a bad person can make a great painting I
think that's idiotic
this book is is really terrific Alice's
Adventures in Wonderland I remember
reading this when I was probably eight
and the characters the the wordplay it's
just it's a lot of fun children's books
from that period are so clever you read
Winnie the Pooh it's incredibly clever
Alice's Adventures in Wonderland
incredibly clever The Wizard of Oz
incredibly clever children's literature
now is I think not clever at all I know
a lot of people love Harry Potter which
is really children's literature Harry
Potter can't hold a candle to Alice's
Adventures in Wonderland it is it is I
think dunderheaded and right on the nose
I'm not a Harry Potter fan but Alice's
Adventures in Wonderland I think is
quite great and and utterly worth
reading okay time for a couple of things
that I hate
okay so first thing that I hate the New
York Times is Mike Rosenberg actually
tweeted out that he was he's very upset
because I guess he's a Seattle Times
reporter actually so he was very upset
because after the Amazon Gold launch
Amazon go launched yesterday and Jeff
Bezos stock gained about 2.8 billion
dollars in value
okay Amazon go or basically these
convenience stores you walk in there's
no attendant you grab your products off
the shelf you walk out no problem it's
charge carry Amazon accounts and and so
Jeff Bezos had a stock game because this
is a cool invention so here's what Mike
Rosenberg tweeted Jeff Bezos made 2.8
billion dollars in one day after his
company introduced technology that
eliminates the need for cashiers all
cashiers in America make an average of
210 million dollars a day combined so
what I'm confused why is that why is
that a thing like that that doesn't make
like what here here's what that's a
stupid point the reason that's a stupid
point is even if you were to assume that
Jeff Bezos is somehow taking money out
of the pockets of a bunch of poor
cashiers okay the reality is that it's
not that he's making 2.8 billion dollars
off cashiers losing money to the tune of
210 million dollars a day that means
that if he saved if he saved the the
entire industry the cost of cashiers for
ten days they would pay for that 2.8
billion dollars right the point is that
you are number one the statistic is
severely flawed they're taking the stock
price which is reflecting the power of a
new technology that is going to affect
the market over time and comparing that
to a one-day take away for cashiers and
the statistic just makes no sense but
the suggestion of course by Mike
Rosenberg is that something terrible has
happened here that the evil Jeff Bezos
has stolen the livelihoods of cashiers
know evil Jeff Bezos just made
technology better and lower your cost at
the supermarket because guess who pays
for those cashiers it's you right when
you go to the supermarket and you pay
for things you're paying the cashier is
why do you think that all of these like
Ralph's is put in these these self
studies self use items right these self
use kiosks where you can checkout
yourself the whole point is to cut cost
what what absolute silliness and lack of
economic understanding okay
other things that I hate too Lester Holt
over at NBC he went to North Korea and
then he proclaimed that he'd been
treated with respect by the North
Koreans we
in North Korea on Saturday we flew the
North Korean state airline it's about an
hour-and-a-half flight from Beijing they
even make an announcement in flight when
you eventually cross the border into
North Korea we quickly pass their
immigrations went through a very lengthy
and very detailed customs inspection of
not only our equipment but our personal
items down to the novels we were reading
even in one case a toothbrush of our
crew members but we had been treated
with respect here we have been invited
and our guests of the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs we stayed in a guest
house outside Pyongyang last night and
then made our way to this ski resort to
get a look at a part of North Korea that
most Americans don't see yeah so what
right so so was so as Walter Durant he
treated by the Soviets there the idea
that they were treated really well by an
evil regime that means the regime is
fine just stupidity
he's raked over the coals as well he
should be okay we'll be back here
tomorrow we will be broadcasting I
believe from Dallas remove around the
country a lot we'll be broadcasting from
Dallas but I will give you the update on
how it went at UConn tonight you can
also watch the UConn broadcast tonight
at yah org I believe we'll also put it
up on our Facebook page and Twitter and
and all of the usual places so check it
out I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Applause]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Aleksandr Oh
audios mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright floor
publishing 2018